a massive container ship has been
dislodged from the banks of the suez
canal after a massive effort to free it
the owner of the ever given says the 400
meter long vessel has been straightened
out but
it is not yet fully afloat it became
wedged in the canal a week ago amid high
winds excavators have been digging out
the side of the canal
while as many as 11 tugboats have been
pulling it back into position
the incident has blocked traffic in the
waterway leaving it
leaving hundreds of cargo ships waiting
in line
well for the very latest we've got chris
cobra here with us from
dw business good morning good morning
now why has it taken nearly a week
to get this vessel halfway dislodged
well we're looking at three factors here
first the ship is extremely heavy second
one is apparently the force with which
the ever given has run aground was was
quite strong and the third one it is a
narrow canal so you don't have really
much
room to maneuver um that said overnight
we know that several dredgers had told a
vacuum vacuumed up
27 000 cubic meters of mud and sand as
you
said it took more than 10 tugboats uh to
at least
partially straighten out the ever given
and it took the moon
because the moon actually over the
weekend the full moon
brought the spring tide which which also
uh helped
along there however the challenges
remain you said um
the the bow is still uh not freed is
it's
they haven't dislodged it yet of the
ship and the high tide
that has been helpful is receding this
week so
the clock is taking there we don't
really know the suez canal
is is part of the one of the busiest
trade routes in
the whole world what's the extent of the
damage
chris to world trade well experts had
been saying um
that the damage is worth about 10
billion dollars
per day that will trade 10 billion a day
yeah and
and here's another figure for you
because of the ever given
uh blocking the canal according to the
canal authority around 370
ships on both sides on each side of the
canal we're waiting for for
passage it is impossible to say what
the individual individual cargo on each
ship is so that could be anything from
video games to toilet paper
uh so it shows you how frail
uh some of the trade links are in
in this situation and and obviously um
this accident
has been a nightmare to egypt as well
the state
canal authority losing about 13 million
dollars each day
in fees of ships not being able to pass
so
that office chair i ordered from my home
office that's probably built in china
it might take a while longer still to
get yeah world commerce
in peril because of a ship blocking a
canal
um could this happen again it sounds
like an almost refreshingly simple
problem doesn't it
a ship just blocking a canal and uh
it is the size of the ships that is part
of the problem here um
uh nowadays these giant freighters are
four times
the size that they have been uh 25 years
ago
the ever given weighs 220 000 tons now
that might not tell you much but it is
the length
of the height of the empire state
building it is
almost half a kilometer long yeah some
call it too
big to sail these kind of kind of ships
and as they keep growing
uh yes the danger of that happening
again persists
chris thank you very much chris cover
from dw business